marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hey everyone uh welcome to vaynerx
presents marketing for the now
australia edition i'm amy bradshaw
business director of vayner australia
and i am here with gary vaynerchuk hey
gary
amy happy birthday i'm gonna make you
blush right off the bat
i don't know if we i don't know if we
planned this on your birthday but i
think it's epic
i think you're amazing it's good to see
you and
it is very you know one of the worst
things about kovid was
i was on a five-year streak of an annual
trip to australia
so this will scratch that itch and hello
everybody in the comments i see you all
on all the live streams
and i appreciate everybody who's
dropping the five five yes big day next
week but
today we are focusing on marketing with
an incredible cast i'll let amy kind of
give us the context
so this is a special one-hour edition
where we have six of australia's very
best marketers here to answer the
question
i like that you're drinking wine and
it's i am australia
i i wish i could say it's a hunter
valley semion but i don't think it is i
wasn't there
ever go ahead um so this episode we've
got a bunch of speakers six of
australia's very best
answering the question how do you breed
a culture of fast decision making
so let us know what you think at
marketing hashtag marketing for the now
and i'm going to kick us off with our
first speaker so
first up we have susan coghill chief
marketing officer of tourism australia
susan is a former ad agency devotee turn
client
from her early days working on apple at
day in los angeles where she once
presented creative to steve jobs on the
beach in hawaii
to learning about young men's grooming
and dating habits for unilever's
axe brand in asia to having kylie
minogue perform a love song from one
country to another for tourism australia
in the uk
susan's career has centred on a belief
in the power of creativity to build
brands
drive business and shape culture as
tourism australia's chief marketing
officer
susan is responsible for driving the
organization's global brand and
marketing strategy
ensuring that australia's tourism
marketing efforts continue to cut
through in the competitive domestic and
international landscape
together with a team of passionate
marketers across the globe susan is
committed to helping australian tourism
bounce back as quickly as possible from
the impact of carbon 19.
welcome susan thank you great to be here
and happy birthday amy
susan is such a pleasure i have so many
questions the rapid nature
of uh marketing for the now won't let me
get to even
any of them but first and foremost how
are you how you know
for the global audience here how is
australia doing
currently because if we see everybody
even flowing
and then we'll get into the question
absolutely look australia is doing well
we have managed the crisis very well
um we have uh you know look governments
that manage the spot outbreaks um
very carefully um and look our our
uh government leadership is making a
decision about keeping our borders
closed for the time being and keeping
a a policy of um managing the virus as
safely as possible we're open to new
zealand finally
um and we're looking forward to when we
can start welcoming international
visitors again and when we can get you
back down gary
i would love that i would love that big
shout out to
uh ig we have we don't do instagram live
too often it's not part of the screen
yard thing the big shout out to them
so uh everybody i see a lot of you have
a lot of questions for susan let's throw
that back
up the hashtag that you can use on
twitter if you want to join the
conversation hashtag marketing for the
now
susan you know how do you breed a
culture of
you know of speed how do you beat a
culture of fast decision making because
i'm sure
if kova taught your bus you know kobe
affected all of us
in business you at the highest levels
you know what what stands out like you
know i
come from entrepreneurship yes
i have an incredible cynical point of
view on big company speed
yep i mean i don't even like vayner
media speed
i i you know and i'm in charge so yeah
sure
and that means it's very hard you know
what does make
fast decision making actually work from
your perspective
yeah look first i'll give you some
context actually because um
we are a uh a government agency not a
government
um department but a government agency we
have an incredible range of stakeholders
you know whether it be our tourism
minister or you know that sort of 250
000 odd tourism operators around
australia
and to be honest the 26 million
australian citizens who are
you know very vigilant about what we do
and how we represent the brand both
domestically and internationally
so look we are um by nature a very
risk-averse
business and we're operating in a time
that is fraught with challenges like we
have never seen before
um if you were to ask me kind of what
the balance was um previously about kind
of being writer being fast you know i'd
say we were 90 10
90 10 90 being fast 10 being um
sorry 90 being right 10 being fast
that shifted in the last year or so
we're probably i don't know 50 50 we
still have to be very mindful
uh you know of reputation um for the for
our national brand
but my god we need to respond very
quickly when we had the bushfire
outbreak last year you know we went from
no domestic marketing
team at all in australia we were focused
on international
inbound um from other countries uh to
setting up a domestic team a domestic
business and getting a
um a whole range of domestic marketing
um content out in market within
i don't know two weeks or so so zero to
an entirely new team and new initiatives
um you know at rapid speed
and we've continued to keep that pace up
as we've you know faced into
the covid um situation both the first
the international board is closing and
what that meant you know we were
we were uh then turning to focus just on
domestic travel but then we
had the the problem with the state
borders starting to close in those
lockdowns
and that meant pivoting yet again to the
type of messaging we could
we could put into market how we could
keep australians
um uh engaged and thinking and planning
and ultimately even booking even if it's
forward bookings for the next holiday
so um yeah we have changed drastically
if you'd uh ask me exactly how we do it
i think we put a lot of
energy and emphasis in the upstream work
so we sweat the strategy early we have a
very clearly defined brand
very clearly defined marketing strategy
both domestically and internationally
we do a lot of stakeholder engagement up
front we make sure that our board
supports where we're going that the
minister's office supports where we're
going
um and that allows us to have a very
clear blueprint uh
for what we need to do and and uh move
quite quickly
reading the comments on you know on
periscope and twitch and and facebook
and youtube here
um knowing there's a lot of smbs
mid-market
entrepreneurs what about when it's not
covered macro
yep you know how how do people make
quick decisions even
susan actually even at your level forget
about an organization or a team
how do you use susan the human yes
how do you think about decisive and
quick decision making
and adjusting you know you know for me
it's easy because there's no board i'm
not publicly held
you know if when i stink i look at
myself in the mirror the next morning go
you're an idiot
you know you know i have a lot of
compassion and empathy that it's easier
for
me to make quick decisions yeah how do
you think about that and how should
people think about that
yeah look for me personally full
transparency i
am i am a deliberator you know i i uh
probably emote outwardly with my team a
lot you know
i have a a uh a board of directors
personally that i use to
to consult on questions uh either about
work or or
any individual decisions i might need to
make
but ultimately at heart i'm a massive
believer in the power of creativity as
uh as amy introduced me
and that for me has always been the
guiding light around how i make
decisions what i commit to
um you know i know that um you know it's
important to
uh feel the fear sometimes and the
decisions that you need to make and you
just need to
do it anyway um so yeah for me it's a
combination i suppose
again that upstream work which is so
important that i'm grounded on
what i'm trying to achieve uh who i'm
serving where i'm going
um i consult the right people around me
and then you know what sometimes you've
got to make the leap and go
i love that final parting thoughts as we
wrap up here these go fast
anything that people uh all the people
that are aspiring after covid to come to
australia you want to give a little plug
oh my god i can't tell you i'm obviously
a new australian i i'm
originally born in america i have
literally the best job in the world
because i'm selling this most amazing
country
um that i fell in love with and inviting
the rest of the world down
we are waiting for you we're ready the
industry cannot wait to start to welcome
you guys back down
and we're gonna make sure that that
glass of wine that you're drinking next
time is
a beautiful uh hunter valley uh semi-on
or my favorite
a margaret river chardonnay thank you
the william estates is one of my
favorite wines in the world
well beautiful thank you for being on uh
thanks jeremy
cheers bye susan
uh before you introduce our next guest
big shout out to mark kang
on facebook who just said that he bought
ethereum which means he is plotting for
my five five
drop oh and lisa buckley amy our
teammate mr buckley is in the uh
in the chat anyway go ahead cool so next
up we have
zach kitchke chief marking marketing
officer of canva
zach joined canberra in 2013 as one of
the earliest employees
since then the visual communications
platform has grown to over 55 million
active
monthly active users across 190
countries with over
5 billion designs created at a rate of
over 100 designs per second
today canberra is growing from strength
to strength with a current valuation of
15 billion us dollars
and over thousand fifteen hundreds or
eight team members around the world
working to empower
everyone to design having worked across
product management communications
human resources before establishing the
global marketing function
zach now oversees all of canvas
international brand and growth efforts
from product marketing to pr and
communications affiliate and performance
marketing
content marketing brand and creating
development welcome zach
hey folks how are you good good
yeah you do night been a while it's been
a long time you know i'm a very proud
you know when i was starting my second
fun which i ended up not doing
um one of the few investments i made was
in canva
along with chloe and all that team and
uh it's just been amazing to watch your
journey
proud of you guys uh love seeing the
crew the last time i was there
you made three four years ago uh what a
success story and uh it's great to see
you
yeah you too why don't you tell the five
people that don't know what canva is
uh and obviously for a lot of people
actually that's a little you know in the
creator ecosystem it's
omnipresent but actually i think a lot
of people here come from different
angles so
why don't i give you one minute on uh
canva and then we'll say uh we'll see
where it is
sure yeah so canva i guess the simplest
way to uh to sort of pitch it
it's a um a simple you know easy to use
online design platform and so we started
out
uh back in 2013 so we've been kind of
going at it for uh for eight years now
and
um you can jump onto camera.com uh drag
and drop design
platform makes it super easy to create
uh you know anything from social media
content through to videos
um even you know t-shirts uh actually
presentations
uh has been become our biggest sort of
design type
um recently and so seeing seeing that
exploding
um as well yeah zach let's get right
into the
the question at hand cause these ten
minutes go like this
canva being such a young company you
know me getting a sense of melody from
those earlier days and the rest of the
team
but you know how many employees now at
canberra
uh just over 1600 now yeah
yeah so you know how how does
canva create a culture of you know fast
decision making and
as a cmo as a key decision maker
do you pride yourself like when you
think about fast decision making
do you see that like i hear fast
decision making i'm like yeah
like that's my [ __ ] jam i have a lot
of friends that i respect tremendously
that are like no no no no
gary i'm a thoughtful you know you know
you know
measure twice cut once i'm like respect
when you hear fast decision making
how do you how do you feel about it uh i
think for us
it's it's sort of an interesting one
because canva has been on this
you know sort of explosive growth
journey uh you know i started back in
2013 and there was
there was five of us back then we're now
1600 people
um we're 55 million you know monthly
active users so 55 million people using
canva
each and every month all around the
world you know 100 languages 190
countries
uh and we've been doubling you know year
on year so i think in the last 12 months
we added
30 million um users the you know the
marketing functions kind of
you know growing incredibly rapidly so i
think uh
you know something that we've found is
you know the company and
the problems that we're solving for um
look completely different you know
every three three months six months
things um things break and so
um that kind of forces uh you know a
fast culture
um we need to be um we need to be moving
quickly just by the
virtue of how we're growing um and i
think you know the way that we've
sort of handled that is um you know a
few things i think it's like
getting the right team in place um you
know uh
you know going going back to your values
in terms of um of decision making but
um also just acknowledging um that we've
all we're all kind of on the
you know the biggest kind of rocket ship
of our lives and yeah
needing to learn as well and so i think
you know something that that uh
is definitely true for me and and you
know i'm true for the team
is um just that culture of always
learning and being kind of comfortable
you know not having all of the answers
um you know everything that we do is
kind of a new problem space to get into
and sort of
new things to learn quick public service
announcement
the concept of bone broth
and wine at the same time is maybe the
greatest combo that nobody knew they
needed
but i'm enjoying it here yes i'm
enjoying the double beverage
like milk and juice or something isn't
that it's a little wild
zach what's the biggest thing you've
learned about speed
at canva uh the biggest thing
i've learned about speed is
uh uh like i think there's there's
decisions that you need to make quickly
um and there's things that you need to
act on and there's decisions that um
you know paid to take a bit of time on
um you know like a couple practical
examples for us
uh you know from a you know during cove
but obviously uh you know
every business and every organization
had to kind of adapt overnight and
um you know we sort of uh uh you know
hit pause and
did a big reset um you know that period
and really for us it was about
you know firstly making sure um you know
we had a handle on what it meant and you
know we're looking after the team and
then looking at the community
and um making sure that we were
supporting them um
you know in that case like you know one
of the things that
uh we sort of did which i think was a
good example and something that you know
we're continuing to try and bake into
how we do things um
you know one of the first things we saw
was actually just this sort of big
change in terms of what people were
searching for on the platform and
the things that people were creating and
you know one little anecdote was um
you know we just saw this huge uptick in
zoom backgrounds um
you know people kind of uh searching for
that content and so really quickly kind
of got together and
um just launched a whole suite of um of
zoom backgrounds and
um you know it was just something a bit
of fun at that point in time but
um you know generated you know huge
amount of uh sort of love and interest
on on social and
you know we've got a whole lot of
coverage off the back of that and so you
know i think
in a marketing context being able to
kind of respond in um you know sort of
real real time to some of those things
um you know something something that i
like that
um what what are the what are the
what actually let me ask you this way
when you think about
executing which is what we really think
about a culture of speed
how much do you think it comes down to
casting
picking the right people on dna
or how much do you think it comes down
to an organization
that has a great training and learning
agenda you know i could you know we're
just getting to that
at vayner 12 years in because we're a
young company too
how much do you think it comes down to
kind candor and optimism
like break it break it down for me on
like
to me i'm most fascinated because i
think a lot of people are going through
different journeys
on casting like i always found that one
[ __ ] person zack with a middle or
upper middle management
role could slow the whole [ __ ] thing
down thoughts
yeah yeah i completely agree with that
uh and i you know i think i would
definitely prioritize
like character um you know and hiring
uh i think you want people that can
learn and flex and they're adaptable
and you know they they're um they're
able to move quickly as well
particularly in a
realm of change um and you know hiring
hiring for that ability to actually
learn uh you know go and collect
information talk to people figure out
what's going on bring that back and
distill it into something that makes
sense and
um and you know it's kind of uh i think
two things really right
being able to set the right goals and
craft a kind of vision and then
um being able to kind of execute and you
know push
push at all costs to um to get there
right i love it zach thank you for your
time i wish you well
continued success good to see you again
next up we have brent smart chief
marketing officer of
iag the australian insurance giant with
leading brands including nrma
and cgu when brent joined in 2017
nrma insurance was ranked 36th strongest
brand in australia by brand finance
now it is the third strongest brand in
the country and its strongest brand in
the insurance
brand in the world this brand strengths
has translated to
commercial success that has seen nrma
insurance win three coveted gold
fees in the last two years previously
brent spent 20 years in the advertising
business
rising to ceo of saatchi and such in new
york on leading new
zealand agency of the decade colenzo
bbdo
originally from melbourne which explains
his love of aussie girls footy
brent lives in bondi same as zach
actually with his wife and three sons
who don't love aussie rules footy quite
as much
thanks for joining us you know
on that on that footy point brent you
know take it from an american football
fan who's one of
his greatest greatest sporting event
experiences
was a playoff footy game remind me brent
i was on a wine trip this was in 2002
the silver and black team collingswood
or
collingwood collingwood i went to a
collingwood
playoff game
gary we call them finals finals respect
i went to a
collingwood finals game knew almost
nothing about the sport had a half a
bottle of
shiraz in me on the way there and tried
to learn it from the guys
that were taking us on this wine trip
and had one of the greatest
sporting experiences in my life the
passion was incredible
and as a passionate american football
fan
the wife and kids scenario you have to
become a dictator brent
this is unacceptable they have to be
passionate
first i'm trying gary yeah i just
respect listen before we get into the
question i just want to uh
i just want to say that it's really
great to be on with you i've admired
your work from afar
uh being in the same ecosystem and it's
a real pleasure i hope you're well
oh thank you gary yeah glad to be here
let's get right into it because these go
quick as you can tell
being in the green room you know you've
been an agency landscape
a real icon as a leader you're now the
cmo of a very large organization
where you've built a lot of brand equity
but but i find it
i you know one of the things that you
know i said earlier i don't know how
long you've been on
vayner itself i feel is not fast enough
for my ambition
you can imagine what my opinion on the
saatchis and the bbdo's are
and then an ieg where you know in short
like i have a lot of
it's not that i have cynical or negative
point of view it's actually compassion
and empathy
knowing human behavior when you think
about
speed fast decision making
is that even an oxymoron or is that some
were you able to bring that energy is
that culturally relevant
is that possible bring it down for us
from your perspective
yeah it's definitely a challenge in a
big insurance company um
you know they're not built for speed uh
and they're built to
minimize risk right that's kind of what
you're doing insurance companies so
so it's it's not easy doing it inside
here but the thing that's been
amazing for me having done 20 years
agency side
is the ability to make decisions when it
comes to ideas so you know i spent 20
years
trying to get clients to buy ideas and
invariably i thought they're buying the
wrong idea
and the great thing now is i'm able to
pick the idea but then create
all the conditions that idea needs to be
great and i actually think that's where
you can bring enormous speed
to any process be really decisive when
you're picking ideas
and then also clear all the barriers
that get in the way of great ideas
getting to market and an insurance
company they are many
uh and so yes i'm chief marketing
officer but i actually see my job as
and this sounds a little bit sort of um
wanky possibly but
my job is to shepherd ideas through this
corporation which is built to kill ideas
uh and i think that's a really important
part of my job on that note
you know i have the great i have the
great luxury of
one of the great honors is i've had some
really strong executives
which is why i admire sochi so much work
at vayner that i've gotten to know and
you know i i you know sachi's so iconic
and vbdl
you know one of my points of view is the
subjectiveness around creative
creates a lack of speed but when i hear
you talk to that
do you feel and this is now a great
question for everybody who's watching
do you feel one of the straight you know
you know we're both starting to get a
little
more gray hairs than we had i see your
beard yes
do you feel as we become older and
there's a lot of kids watching a lot of
executives in our similar spots
do you think learning from the past and
knowing not
what to knowing what not to do is an
incredible
way to get faster thoughts yeah i'd
probably answer that a little bit
differently i think
experience and i think i think people
who have the experience to really trust
their gut and
trust their intuition i think that's a
beautiful skill set that's that's
becoming rarer and rarer in in certainly
in corporations
uh and so i think that and that can
enable things to go really really quick
right because if you've got good
intuition
a good gut then you're going to make a
call about an idea where other people
would probably want more information or
other people would probably want some
research or wants a validation or
whereas whereas i think you know the
really great people i've worked with in
places like saatchi and bb
throughout my career they've got this
incredible intuition around ideas and
and i i've thought a lot about can you
learn it i definitely can get better at
it but i think there are some people who
just have this incredible
i totally by the way you know
i can get better at tennis i'm not gonna
be novak djokovic i can get better
at boxing i'm not going to be you know
floyd mayweather
i agree with you like i i think that we
have this incredibly
uncomfortable talent uh issue with
talent
where we have to recognize you know
alan harker our our global cfo you know
just said thank you because i'm
referring to him as one of the good
executives
he's going to be naturally more
comfortable around numbers than i am
that's just the punchline of the game
like you know people to your point i
couldn't agree more i think where
actually while i've got you because i
admire you a lot and i think this will
work
how much do you think decisions around
creative
are political and a little bit audacious
and a little bit ego
and a little subconscious this is my
leverage point i'm fascinated by
i loved you you just complete i already
liked you from afar you completely won
me over with
it's my job to get things shipped i
think that
the marketing and agency and brand
ecosystem is based a lot on and i i
i don't view this as a bad thing i think
it's unconscious
subconscious bias around knowing that
your
opinion is your leverage and then thus
awards headlines become an ecosystem
and it comes at the expense of speed and
shipping things
thoughts on that yeah it's interesting i
i i think sometimes that can be a
negative thing and i think sometimes it
can actually be a really positive thing
right because what
what's what's absolutely proven in all
the effectiveness literature is fame
is the most critical thing if you want
your brand to be effective and you know
that right that's what you do really
well dana right you make brands famous
you get them talked about
you get them in culture right so so part
of that ego around
i want to do famous work and i want my
brand to be famous i think he's
incredibly positive ego i think i think
where it can be quite negative ego is
when it gets caught up with
i want credit for this you know it's my
name on this and all that kind of stuff
it's really a big problem you're saying
hey make it about the work the second
you start becoming selfish
you know it becomes a mockery absolutely
and and i
actually questioned it i'm being wildly
selfish at this point because i'm
enjoying this yeah sure
you know i've been spending a ton of
time you know i have a lot of audience
in australia
um and obviously now with amy coming
back to her roots we're gonna start
getting more serious about the
marketplace
it's really been one of my favorite
place on earth because
i it was a place i fell in love with in
my early age because of the wine
business
yeah making work
famous as you know as the cmo of this
insurance company now
on the juxtaposition of traditional
digital
traditional digital what an incredible
time for us to be alive
because the only other time that i and
i'm a good i'm bad at most things but
i'm good at history
we are living through similar challenges
that marketers had when we went from a
radio predominant
society to a television predominantly
society
absolutely we are clearly going from a
from a marketing standpoint
from a tv commercial predominant society
to between ott social you know for the
first time i'm seeing people not named
me
talk about things like brand is being
built in social media
how are you thinking about that given
your incredible background of knowledge
in one ecosystem how do you challenge
yourself on
speed of education whether it's nft or
tick-tock or
influencer you know you're still in the
prime of your career
but you have this incredible expertise
and in a genre how do you think about
that as a human because i think that
will help a lot of people challenge
themselves
on evolution yeah so a few things first
thing um
my kids right i've got three kids and
and they are unbelievable educators
when it comes to tick tock and and some
of the things they're doing it's it's
fascinating
how they think about brands and and um
so that's
i i find them a constant and what what
are there are just brands
i've got three boys 13 10 and seven
yeah so and it's just and it's just so
interesting i mean the idea of
i'm going to create my own content
monetize that that's just kind of like
what you do for your part-time job now
you know
you're a teenager everybody's an
entrepreneur in a career
because of entry is so low exactly so
there's that the other thing is i've
hired people who bring a very different
skill set to me and one of the smartest
things i think i've done is in the sort
of whole
content social space is don't hire
marketers
i i hired someone from the publishing
media world to run all that
and it's a completely different mindset
you know it's publishing every day it's
what's going on in culture
and and whereas and it's not sort of
working to that strict
sort of framework and process that
marketers like right and that's totally
that's been a great change for us in
australia from your point of view with
this incredible seated table
do you think that people have realized
they can get scale and build brand and
social or did they
do you think still that they think of it
as a little
appetizer to the above the line and you
push down i think look i think the smart
brands have so just take us for example
nrma insurance so we're in a low
engagement category right people don't
want to engage with insurance much in
social but we've massively changed that
and i can now show that like if you look
at all the engagements in social in our
category in australia we get 80
of them a market share our market shares
only 12 nationally for our biggest brand
so
so so we dominate and i i can show the
positive impact that's had on our brand
it's a
it's an absolute competitive advantage
for us but i think it's and not all
right i think i think you've got to be
doing that really well
and and doing the brand fundamentals
incredibly well too right
have has there been sophisticate where
we've really cracked the code is using
social brand building
to get consumer insights to then go up
with the above the line uh versus let's
say
doing the research work and pushing down
have you seen nuances on that
yeah look at we do that as well right
like a really interesting one for us
because in our category the bushfires
obviously had a massive impact in
australia we're the biggest insurer new
south wales which had the biggest brunt
of the bushfires and we were responding
daily hourly to what's going on around
the bushfires and we we felt we had to
but what was interesting we got
unbelievable insights from our customers
that were able to then use in our
marketing
for instance and what's this is since
the bushfires like the bushfires now
you know over a year ago um what we've
now what we've found is there's still a
whole bunch of people who need mental
health
help in this country and we saw that in
social we saw it through social
commentary
and we kind of launched a new campaign
with with lifeline which is a
sort of phone line that supports people
to say we're here to help you still so
that's a classic example where
what we heard in social totally informed
a really big brand action for us so i
think
they have to live together and i find
personally i find insights from social
way more actionable than market research
insights
you know this was even better than i
dreamed it brent thank you so much
thanks gary cheers man
oh next up uh we have a guest who i
think gary might match
your energy we're joined by melissa
hopkins chief marketing officer of
optus as chief marketing officer of
optus which is an australian leader in
telecommunications which delivers
cutting-edge
communications and entertainment
services melissa officially joined optus
in australia in november 2016
and leads the team for all customer
faking facing marketing and engagement
a self-confessed tech freak she is
renowned for creating impact with brands
with bold and ambitious campaigns in
complex and challenging environments
in january 2020 optus was recognised as
australia's strongest brand
and was awarded umbrella marketing team
of the year in november that year
melissa was named
third gmo 50. prior to update
was a global head of brand for vodafone
in london and previously led brands such
as absolute vodka
the british army nestle and fujitsu
melissa has lived and worked across
europe asia pac the us
and the middle east and has been a guest
lecturer at the london school of
economics
a contributor to fast company magazine
and a mentor to various us-based
startups
she's an advocate for mental health and
sits on the board of batia
welcome melissa thank you thanks
hey gary i'm so chuffed i'm just pissed
i'm like drinking wine
but isn't it like in the morn you know
look what's going on in my background
it's getting late i'm allowed what time
is it for you
uh oh like it's 10 o'clock in the
morning yeah i'm not sure if wine is
super appropriate in that reality
melissa i love your energy i'm a fan let
me get right into the question
how do you in such an incredible
organization think about speed
you know as a cmo you know this has been
the theme here
you know the creative subjective
opinions
and tact and talent versus putting
things out in the world
what's your gut on that question um look
i think to be honest it's just part of
my
dna so um i make quick decisions i don't
make foolish decisions i make quick
decisions and i believe i can make quick
decisions because i'm a master
of of my craft um i get deeply
frustrated when things go slow
but if i'm really honest and you talk
about fast decisions i think a whole lot
of people don't either make the fast
decisions
or they [ __ ] about not being able to do
them because they're terrified
that with every fast decision becomes
huge accountability like you know
it's it's on your shoulders when you
make a fast decision you can't hide
behind a system or a process
talk talk you normally because i'm
looking i'm reading all the comments
everybody's watching
on linkedin facebook youtube i'm reading
i'm trying to make the show better
you know talk about accountability i
love you for bringing up that word i'm
working on a new book that
i'm dropping in november i have an nft
project uh
that i'm dropping next week that has a
focus on one character around
accountability
how much don't you believe you know i
love that you brought that up you've
completely inspired me right now
don't you believe that accountability is
incredibly underrated as a gateway to
happiness
oh massively massively i mean um
we only have one life and and we're
responsible for it i've made some
tragic decisions both at work and and to
be honest i probably made some pretty
crappy personal ones as well at times
but um uh
i believe that i'm happier and and more
fulfilled because i don't allow other
people to drive my decisions
so you know look obviously in business
um i'm working with a team and i've got
to be
sensible but one of the best pieces of
advice i got many years ago
from an awesome ac day guy called glenn
jacobs actually out of new york
um you know he said to me the only
person driving this car mel is you
stop stop saying everybody else is so um
accountability equals happiness and
optimism to be
to be honest but it also you know i got
wrinkles
because i make decisions every day and
um my head's above the parapet and i
could get shot down for making the wrong
one
i love that what about speed you know
one of the you know i think we're two
peas in the pod and i've always
kind of like in our interactions believe
that
do you you know after hearing your
answer there let me just go to the
logical next step
do you believe it's your responsibility
to create safety
and eliminate fear which then leads to
fast decision-making
and speed oh that's a good question
i don't believe i make unsafe decisions
but um i'm going to give you two
examples of where fast decisions happen
every day
the best one was being spoilt enough to
work with the british army
for four years amazing right um
that that institution is based on fast
decision making when you're in a combat
situation
oh right like that's when you're like
i mean you want to talk about fast
decision making
um you know and and they're trying to do
so
um now they try to do it in a safe form
obviously there are lives at risk i'll
talk about another passion of mine
formula one
you know you're going at 300 bloody
kilometers an hour
that is fast decision making every
single day now they've got
safety around them but there is always
going to be some risk with
um fast decision making but i'm an
adrenaline junkie
so you know there is risk
i call crash are you a bungee jumper and
like all that kind of [ __ ]
yes i've jumped off yes i've done all of
that yeah
yeah you know what's funny unless i'm
really legitimately not scared of
anything except the following three
things
the health of my family petrified
like i know i think i'm superman with
one very simple kryptonite
my mom or dad calling me and saying
they're dying like that to me feels like
i wanna
yeah i like like this you know two
snakes melissa i do not [ __ ] with snakes
i don't like snakes either i hate them
number three which is ironic because my
nft project next week has a lot of
snakes in it number three
heights you don't seem to be scared of
heights i
don't [ __ ] with heights yeah you see the
thing is
i'm not great with heights so i'm
actually not great
flying but um i'm
we're gonna walk in an airplane oh yeah
i mean and i've flown all around the
globe
i'm crap flying oh i'm amazing i i
actually am
more comfortable in a plane than my own
bed i'm so
nice night
um no i think i'm scared of heights but
again it's the adrenaline i'm pushing
myself out of my boundaries so
you know i bungee jumped twice in my
early 20s and then
two years ago i i jumped off when i was
what then 45
in new zealand again and um i was
terrified
but the feeling afterwards was damn
amazing
two comments from the gallery john kelly
has the same fears as me big love
post king says move out of new york
new tax proposal whopping 58 if you're
over 400 000.
on the record i'll pay 99 tax
to live in the greatest city in the
world because i'm crazy as [ __ ] in this
action
final question what what what can people
do to get faster
um what can people do to get faster stop
deliberating i mean there's this really
fantastic quote
um that mckinsey came up with um that
managers at a typical fortune 500
company spend half a million
hours a year deliberating making
decisions
right so um i think stop stop
deliberating stop
asking for permission um make a call and
and take the risk
do it safely um but it will empower you
i love you good to see you melissa bye
see you gary cheers
our next speaker is alexander meyer
chief marketing officer of the iconic
alex is a people-centric
innovation-driven and purpose-led chief
officer for australia and new zealand's
leading online fashion
sports and lifestyle retailer at the
iconic
a business in which he and his team are
championing the conversation on
diversity and inclusion
was lossy body positivity sustainability
and fashion
alex and his team focus on how to
successfully connect brand and
creativity with data empowered decision
making and martech excellence
he's grateful to have gained
intercontinental leadership experience
in global regional and local business
setups of different sizes
such as adidas vans and even pre-office
while having a steady focus on bridging
the intersection between brand product
and sales he's all about driving human
connectivity
for him it's all about the people
employees customers and partners alike
alex also notes that his personal
experience of growing up in east germany
where his dad was 15 when world war ii
ended and he
himself was 15 when the berlin wall fell
has shaped his thinking and being more
than anything else
welcome alex thank you amy
hi gary nice to meet you such a pleasure
thanks for having me
you know being born in the same part of
the world as you i'm going to go into a
different part of the question because i
was very inspired by that
how much do you think your ability to be
grateful
because you lived through those two
iconic events you know at one through
your father's eyes one through your own
eyes
i don't know you and immediately
literally have goosebumps
because i know that you have gratitude
because you have context of how it can
be
yeah yeah no i mean
gratitude comes through radical changes
in life
that you have to go through and adapt
with and
it has really not only shaped how i'm
grateful for things but also how i think
about things and how i stay agile about
things
well you just you just you took
everything out of me but i'm going to
try to get everybody to see it
do you believe that you're able to be
fast you said agile
because you have business and
perspective you know you want a real
secret about me alex
i think the reason i'm very good at
business is because i don't care about
money or business
yeah no it makes sense yeah i know it
does this which is why you're forced to
let go
and it and it and you're much easier to
get into the flow of things
the reason i'm sharing it with you just
inspired by that 15 and 15. i've never
said this i know a lot of fans on here
that's the truth like i actually don't
give a [ __ ]
about the money or even business itself
i'm
i like the game of business because i
can play it forever because i like games
yeah and i wonder if you find yourself
being able to flow quickly
because you have such context of how
much harder it can be
because of you and your father's life
and perspective
do you think that has led to you being
fast
yes i think so because it creates a
sense of vulnerability you know
change can happen all the time a week
before the fall of the berlin wall
or even a week before covet put the
whole world into lockdown nobody would
have ever thought and believed something
like that can happen
but if you've radically experienced it
and if your whole identity is at
question at the age of 15
you're forced to just realize that
you're not connected to a location
or a certain thoughts of identity that
you've been
you know molded by in essence so once
you've gone through that you
you find a lot more comfort in the
uncomfortable i think
and that's actually what i think what
i'm always trying to greet as a culture
is in essence two aspects it's
transparency and vulnerability
transparency because people in essence
really love
context and it's much easier to take
them on the journey
to you know if you need to shift and
change and vulnerability because it
makes you
be able to listen and observe and have
empathy and from that point of view
uh you know once you're you know
building a culture of transparency and
vulnerability it's much easier to shift
and change all the time
so yeah no i fully agree gary i love
that alex
how how can organizations or even humans
people that have who are employees
watching and or
are entrepreneurs from your perspective
with your wisdom how can people get
faster
i mean for me there's a there are
probably two main things first of all
always stay curious
that's the number one thing for
everything like don't get used to your
environment don't get used to the setup
don't get used to your chart
just stay curious to always discover new
things because it creates a sense of
openness
um and that's the same for individuals
and for teams
but then the other one is we've
developed early a mantra in
alignment between the marketing team and
our sustainability team
that we call progress over perfection
just dare to lean
in at the end of the day sometimes you
need to put the egg before the chicken
and the problem here is that a lot of
businesses
are scared of you know um the social mob
and and shitstorms of sorts but don't be
scared of it because all you have to do
is
trial things do things and if it's
negative learn from it and show that
you're receptive
show that you're learning from something
that you did so
take away the fear by just doing and
then
whilst you're doing things and whilst
you're leaning in whilst you're taking a
stand
whilst you're taking decisions that
might not be the right ones
that you're always able to learn and
take things on board and that's what
we're trying to live by as a company
and we're lucky because we're only 10
years old and we've in essence been born
in the court of the public eye
we built our business on the back of
social and search and only afterwards
like you described
before when talking to brand based on
the data and
the realities that we found also went up
in the funnel um
to really develop audiences but it's
really all based on that online
experience
because it's real people yeah yeah yeah
i know 100
i'm i'm blown away by the audacity of
classic marketers
sitting in boardrooms thinking the six
of them are the smartest [ __ ] people
on earth
when we have the internet i don't know
if you've heard about it alex it's
called the internet there's people
yeah yeah i mean it is really the
greatest time to be alive as a marketeer
100
like there's so much uh free opportunity
for you to learn and connect
and and really use technology as a
positive here to
to drive that human connectivity you
know and and how you show up and how you
use it in essence so
i always say on the back of something
that our ceo once formulated in the
discussion that we had
online as a mindset not a channel and
because
you know we didn't we didn't have we
didn't have a
high traffic on the heist or a lot of
traffic on the high street
you need to from the get-go not only
develop a product that people want to
maybe habitually use
you also need to find ways for them to
come to you in the first place
and so in that essence when you're in
online pureplay business you have the
advantage if you do it well to really
learn what people are about
and to react with agility all the time
and in our case we're a retailer we
represent
at any given moment in time 1 300 brands
and 80 000 products on site so we're
forced to
shift focus and priorities here and
there
you made a tremendous call out for all
the kids that are watching
my number one piece of advice is to work
in retail for a year
yeah i would agree with you i cannot
believe you know
i thought that i was doing my parents a
gift
by giving them my first 10 years out of
college to build their business for them
and then i was going to do my thing and
it's one of the greatest accomplishments
of all time for me
i gave i gave back to my immigrant
parents right
in hindsight these you know i always
knew i was smart enough to know that the
memories
and spending that time with my dad was
something that one day when he wasn't
with me
would forever fulfill me what i did not
know at 22 when i
when i made this big decision was oh
[ __ ]
retail and i was very unique i i had the
luxury that i was in retail
and my and sasha vaynerchuk cared about
sales alex
he didn't care about brand he cared
about sales every day
i knew that i was going to leave one day
so i cared about brand because
i didn't want the company to collapse
when i left because i knew that i was
such a driver so i focused heavily on
brand because brand sustains longer it
takes longer to decay
yeah 100 what i didn't know was retail
was going to teach me so much i mean
it's unbelievable to me how it's very
obvious to me when i
am competing with academics philosophers
you know creatives their lack of retail
experience being
in there with humans is a real real
you know disadvantage for them and and
you know the interesting umbrella that i
see with retailers it spans across two
extremes on one hand they say retail is
detail and you need to basically know
everything and be on the pulse all the
time
you look at numbers all the time and all
those kind of things but at the same
time it also requires you to be agile
and fast all the time
so you kind of need to know everything
and you need to be fast
and so it really expands your horizon on
so many levels
you know kimberly k wells goes garyvee
knows what an end cap is gotta respect
that not only kimberly do i know what an
end cap is
the innovation i did with an encap for
15 years
like i literally watched human beings
walk through a store
for 12 hours a day for two decades
i just know what humans do huge school
yeah
yeah alex parting thoughts on how people
can get faster
i mean for me it is really about the the
words that i mentioned before stay
curious be transparent
and and require and and and request
transparency
from your leaders from your business
from your peers you know obviously i'm
sorry i should have asked that question
better obviously you mentioned that but
i mean
as a leader of people how do you make
them you know
you can say that yeah of course
we actually make that happen so so one
of the things that i always found very
useful is if you bring the squad
cross-collaborative idea into
accountabilities
so if you mix the matrix idea with
accountability
i basically try to train people to be a
functional leader but at the same time
be responsible for other topics
across the team or the business at the
same time
and so it's very easy for us to tune in
with the rest of the business so this
kind of squat meets metrics
and accountability point i think is a
really good one and then the other one
for me is
break up budgets in different ways in
different times and break up work charts
at different times in different ways
so basically force some sort of change
into the team naturally also when the
times are good
it's it's it's something that evolves
you know change responsibilities change
the org chart change the budgets and
metrics you look at
and uh and through that uh foster
constant collaboration learning
and with that also of course always
trial allow for trial and error in
essence in your culture and your team
the rest will come by itself
alex i appreciate you stay well my
friend thank you you too gary
oh last up we have josh grace josh is
samsung australia's chief marketing
officer
and was recently recognized as bp
marketer of the year
as cmo he's responsible for driving the
brand growth of samsung in australia in
a business that stretches across mobile
wearables tablets tv sound home
appliances display monitors and digital
displays
prior to this he ran marketing across
asia for abbott labs out of singapore
his early career flourished in
advertising before his moved client side
during this time josh rose to become
part of leo burnett sydney's executive
team
whom the one report recognized as a top
10 agency in the world
he also happens to be a two-time sailing
world champion
and represented australia at the sydney
2000 olympics thanks for joining us
today josh
hi thanks hey how are you
good man josh let's get right into it
you're cmo of a
major market for one of the biggest
brands in the world
the you know i i've had the luxury of
interacting with the brand through the
years
and have a lot of respect for it very
very
you know driven from its mothership
you know which has its own you know when
you're a global company
you know how do you create speed
in such a environment yeah well
i think you've actually highlighted that
the job's quite easy in samsung because
for 50 years it's done nothing but
innovate
at speed and the culture that exists in
the business is one of speed
you know i think we probably launch you
know 50 products a year on average i've
lost count of how many products the team
is launching
um and so the speed is kind of inherent
in the business
from its inception i think where the
speed has to be created is in the
communications realm where
at a local market level you have that
responsibility
and and really at that point it's about
creating
from my perspective a space for the guys
to actually operate in that they can
they can operate at speed with
through your career where what
actually since we're wrapping up here
what have you seen
that stops speed fear
you know fear's the enemy of creativity
fear is uh
you know a deer stops in the headlights
it is the enemy so what you've got to do
is create courage
and create an environment where people
are prepared to take a risk and not
worry about it and
you know i think one thing about samsung
is it's really good at that actually
that
you know one of my old bosses used to
say it's much better to be far
to be wrong than to be slow and which is
you know quite an interesting thing for
a president of a subsidiary to say
but you know he was really just trying
to say just take a risk guys
and and the current president's the same
he really just wants us to try stuff
even if it doesn't work he'd rather be
tried
and we failed and we learnt and we get
on and try the next thing
who in your career mentored
around speed and or what event
allowed you to become more fearless or
what
variable eliminated fear from you was it
experience was a parenting
or was it a mentor
i think it was an experience and amy
touched on it with the sailing right
i think first of all i was a young kid
starting my career and i had to make a
decision am i going to keep
trying to pursue the career ladder with
my peers or am i going to go off for
four years to say around the world and
race in all these exotic places and yeah
there was an element of fear but i guess
the payoff was pretty good as well
um but i think actually the the lessons
of
olympic level racing are really relevant
for marketing
in that there were two things that drove
our success that helped us win the
worlds the first was
keep it simple we say yes you know keep
it simple stupid
and the second was preparation prevents
poor performance
and so you know learning how to do
something and do it in a very simple way
over and over again
creates that reflex action that you need
to be able to operate in a fast
environment
and when you're racing the world's best
competitors that's what you need to be
able to do you need to be able to
execute your moves
in that moment and i think melissa
before was a great example of someone
who has built a reflex
ability around being able to operate in
a marketing environment at speed and
it's the same thing
she's done it over and over again and
she's just able to execute now with
instinct where
others don't and so i think what people
have to do is just start doing it
like just take some small risks make
sure you're doing it around something
simple to start with and execute it and
just keep going and once you do that
it'll get easier josh what keeps
a brand from samsung like for samsung
from being in and i'm not specifically
speaking of samsung and definitely not
specifically of samsung in australia
big brands why are they slow or feel
at a place in new places like clubhouse
or tik tok or
influencers why do big brands struggle
with doing new things
right yeah well i think
bureaucracy and scorecards you know um
in some regards the bureaucracy is
essential when you're running an
organization at this scale i think
there's a couple hundred thousand people
that work at samsung so
you do need it but you know the
unintended consequence is it does create
checks and balances which are the enemy
of
creativity in that sense and so
you know for us our products especially
the mobile products are at the heart of
social
you know it's we can't not be a part of
tick tock we can't not be a part of
snapchat or instagram or pinterest even
so
we have to be playing in that field
because the content is being consumed on
the devices that we manufacture
so it's just natural for us but i think
it's very easy to see why other
organizations would have those barriers
and not be able to embrace it the way it
should be
well i've got you for two more minutes
what what social
networks if any do you consume and enjoy
well i've vicariously lived through tick
tock and snapchat because i've got a 15
year old girl so
i think i know all about snapping my
best friend and spying on where they all
live day to day i was
she was doing it this morning while i
was driving at a school but uh
for myself it's more instagram and it's
facebook um
and principally because of my passion my
passion you know are sailing for example
and i just love to be able to follow and
stay in touch
with everything that's going on in an
environment so you know that's the
beauty of what social does it
brings those communities together and
enables you to stay connected with
whatever floats you vote
i love that what is what is um
what is the fastest thing you think
you and your team are doing right now
what like when you break down the
molecules of the org
whether it's meetings you know for
example if you ask me that question i
would say
huh uh probably the fact that i'm very
passionate about doing five and seven
and
ten minute meetings because almost
everybody i know in the world
makes those 30-minute meetings and one
of the reasons you know everyone's like
garyvee you hustle you're burned down
like i [ __ ] sleep eight hours a day
it's that i'm very effective and fast
during the day and one of the fastest
things i do
that i think is unusual is i do a lot of
five and ten minute meetings
when i ask you that question is there
anything that you can point to that you
feel
leads to speed
look i think that the team coverts
created a really extraordinary
environment for all of us right and the
one thing i think is just the ability
for everyone to check in daily and stay
connected
our team has you know has become really
good i think
at despite the fact that i'm in the
office a lot of us are now working
remotely
and we've just become really good at
that quick check-in
and to move things on with agility
using the power of the networks and
technology that's been created for us
and i think that's been one of the
brilliant things at covet is really that
it's
accelerated this usage of technology in
some really positive ways 100
this mixed world we're going to leave in
is going to be great josh thank you so
much continued success my friend
thanks gary cool thanks gary
and thank you for everyone joining this
special edition of marketing for the now
australia it's
awesome to be able to highlight some of
the cmos that we've got down here and
the talent that's happening in australia
i've got a note to speak about the next
show on thursday the 20th of may
from 12 to 2 p.m but gary i know it's a
big passion of yours right now so if
there's anything you want to say about
this episode dedicated to nfts yes
everybody's watching
the marketing for the now on the 20th i
think is going to be the biggest episode
that we've ever put out
we're going to be talking about nfts
from a brand standpoint
which is insane and obviously i will be
15 days removed from what's going on on
the fifth which i actually
wanted to spend two seconds on while i
have this whole audience because i'm
getting bamboozled by everybody about
this
um so yes we have marketing for now and
i don't want to bore you amy
but hang with me here yes the 20th
please register please go to
mftn.vaynerx.com to make sure you
register
and don't miss it it's going to be crazy
and really impactful for you
quick little tidbits before i bounce out
of here uh
you definitely need a non-custodial
wallet
uh main probably preferably meta mask
for everybody who's watching
um i just posted an article
on my blog for for the fifth i know all
of you are asking
it is a dutch auction so the tokens are
gonna drop not all of them on the fifth
and they're gonna go down in price i've
told a lot of you that you should have
at least one
ethereum because the floor of the entry
level tokens is 0.5 and there's some gas
fees
i have no idea if people are going to
pick them off at higher prices
so you know i'm very excited about this
you're going to be blown away with what
i did in the smart contracts
the ambition is to make this when you
see it and understand it you will
understand that i built it for the
community
you know my greatest ambition is to see
what happens and then make sure i do all
the actions to make sure it's a great
investment um
i do think nfts are high risk and i
can't this is not financial advice but
i'm very passionate about it
i'm very excited amy i expect you to buy
one so
make sure you get your metamask and
ethereum loaded uh may 5th and then may
20th marketing for the now
big episode on nfts uh i'm going to
tweet out the link right now garyvee on
twitter
to the five things you should know about
may 5th uh that will help a lot of you
asking a ton of questions
uh here we go see ya bye everyone say